the German press are running hard with
this story on the data hack of hundreds
of politicians and includes members of
the cabinet here in Germany Chancellor
Angela Merkel herself and the President
of Germany frankfurter Steinmeier among
many many others but it's not just
politicians that have been the victim of
this err this data breach also comedian
Yan's Banamine and rapper martyria also
caught up in this now of course if
there's talk of hacking and data
breaches the knives immediately come out
for Russia and that is what's happened
in a lot of the articles we've seen here
so far what we do know about the data
that had been hacked into is that it's
been called non highly sensitive data it
includes things from the politicians
this is like job applications err party
memos and lists of party members our
spokesperson for the German government
said an investigation is underway into
this hack the federal government is
taking this very seriously the only
thing we can say about the hack attack
now is that we're working on that the
authorities are working very hard to
understand what happened lakes like this
have to be handled with a great care
because fake information can be
propagated however the government can
say that no sensitive political data was
published so far no official claims that
Russia was behind this and no evidence
presented to that end but this isn't the
first time that we've seen a big media
campaign in Germany pointing the finger
of blame at Russia when it comes to
online shenanigans before the 2017
elections the papers were rife with how
are the Russians going to hack or
interfere with our elections post the
2017 elections there was a lot more
navel-gazing articles saying why didn't
rush a-tryin hack or interfere in these
elections as we heard from the spokesman
person from the government there this
investigation ongoing we'll be looking
into this as it develops
you